comic-con rolls on clips teasers posters
casting TV shows movies all this stuff
but you know what there's only one thing
I'm going to talk about it's gotta be
after whoo
we have gotten a one-minute trailer for
this year's Christmas special Peter
Capaldi's last story as the doctor
called twice upon a time and I have some
thoughts on it and no I am in no way
addressing the 13th Doctor thing in this
one at all I am done talking about that
for a while so first off this seems like
a random thing but I feel the need to
point out here because I've started
rewatching compiled these oldest stuff
like going back to the series 8 and I
really love his hair now so much more
than before he had time of tight
cropping I love the long wild hair and
it's just it feels much more doctorís to
me but we actually don't even start with
Capaldi we start with Peter Bradley and
I like that we starting black and white
I like that it fades into color I expect
that's probably not something that will
happen in the episode proper and that it
was done just for the sake of this promo
but I think it's cool I like how it just
firmly establishes him as the first
doctor possibly for those who didn't
watch an adventure in space and time
though if you haven't watched an
adventure in space and time you should
it's great and we get a little bit of a
hint of what the problem seems to be
with the whole idea of them stuck in a
moment in time well of course we have no
indication of what has caused that
whether it is the doctor himself in
either meeting with himself or possibly
what are you doing to delay his return
regeneration might be was throwing
everything off I hope that's not it
I don't particularly want basically the
whole episode to be just him having to
get over himself and just accept his own
regeneration because that's what's
growing everything up I don't like that
as a premise that was that was one of
the major things that really bothered me
about Father's Day if I was to reach
back aways because the solution to that
problem was so obvious immediately I
just hate that they dragged it out with
the characters just not letting the
obvious solution happen that bothers me
it's not impossible to pull off but it's
really
Foucault we're getting Mark Gatiss as
some sort of British soldier II person
I'm putting even odds as to whether or
not he's playing the Brigadier I which I
would be perfectly okay with I put my
reservations about the idea of bringing
back well specifically earlier
incarnations of the doctor but in broad
terms bringing back over characters
having them played by new actors and I'm
still wary about it but I'm going to
reiterate it's not the idea inherently I
think it can be done it can be done well
I think David Bradley is going to be an
example of doing it well I just don't
like the precedent that a sense that I
don't want the show to ever get
willy-nilly and careless about it
because they could really start screwing
up the legacy of some great characters
and some great performers if they overdo
it or they cast it on or what-have-you
so the practice makes me nervous but you
know certainly the specific instance
with David Bradley I'm down for if this
does turn out to be the Brigadier I'm
down for that if it's not totally fine
with that - I kind of like that we seem
to be getting a little bit of Peter
Capaldi in Grumpy mode as well because
I'm kind of the tail end of series 10
especially you know he was very much in
got to save people got to say people got
to say people and he's a bit less grumpy
and this is odd coming from me because I
think he was probably a little overly
grumpy in that first series that he had
but at the same time I kind of liked
that we're getting that back so we get
like one more taste of it because we got
it what the when the guy asked you know
is one of you a doctor just like are you
trying to be funny there's just
something about that that responds I'm
like okay I think given the
circumstances he has a right to be
grumpy and Bill is coming back which I'm
not going to be as mad about that about
this as Clara coming back after her
perfectly fine death because but here's
the thing at this point much like how
I'm very sick of the companion template
being young attractive women from modern
day era earth
I'm also very tired of this no companion
who leaves can just have their eggs at
be their exit they have to come back in
some way for some additional button on
it because we
gotten it with rose we got it with
Martha we got it with Donna we got it
with Amy we got it with Clara now we're
going to get it with Bill and it's just
a pattern I want to see broken now in
terms of that pattern not every
individual instance of it was awful some
of them worked really well I think the
way that Rose was brought back works
very well I think the way that Martha
was brought back worked not quite as
well Donna for me worked I know for some
other people didn't Amy's moment was
simple enough and you know just
buttoning the very end of Matt Smith's
run I thought it was fine
Clara her thing coming back and
hell-bent I really didn't like so I mean
the use of this thing can go either way
can be good can be bad but it's happened
for every major companion now in new who
I'm sick of it how about when they leave
they're done that's it
I'm really tired of a character's exit
not really being their exit because i
get emotionally invested in the fact
that that was the last time we were
going to see them and i don't like my
investment in that being taken for
granted is going all here they are again
with my budget you know i haven't yet
gotten to the point where I'm going to
not allow myself to get emotionally
invested because I figure they're just
going to do this kind of crap but I
might be there now after this I don't
want to be there I want to be able to
fully enjoy every moment every exit
every death I want to take it for what
it is and absorb it and just deal with
that I don't want that experience
undermined in this case very nice
episode I know we got lumps in between
but come on I don't like that I have to
say this because in isolation I'd be
fine with it
I loved bill that was great I'd be happy
to see more of her but I'm sick of this
pattern so there's my one big
reservation that I'm going to be going
into the last episode for Peter Capaldi
with twice about a time apparently it's
nice yes that's fine as a title I don't
get too hung up about the titles as far
as those go but there's things that I am
pumped for looking forward to one thing
I'm really not something that I'll be
curious about in terms of whether Mark
Gatiss is playing somebody or just being
standard British officer guy
I look forward to him anyways his
writing can go either way I think he was
a better writer on Sherlock than he was
on Doctor Who as much as I take issue
with the final series of Sherlock's but
his right knee on Doctor Who has never
been great for me I pretty much liked
all his appearances I've seen him as an
actor though so I'll be happy to see him
thrown in the mix so those are my
thoughts on the trailer for twice upon a
time the upcoming Doctor Who Christmas
special have you seen it what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listening to the
council of geeks podcast or I am also
one half of beat punch like a girl
podcast both available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]